t alors sillage raffy vous êtes allé
dans en bretagne sur l'île de groix à
propos d'une cure elle qui est un petit
peu vieille comme le monde
oui c'est exact on peut parler de caurel
en effet le ministère de l'éducation a
ouvert récemment deux classes de 6e et
5e dans l'île de groix donc est au sud
de la bretagne au large de lorient et
dans cette île après le cm2 les enfants
sont souvent obligés de partir sur le
continent pour entrer en sixième et
s'ils veulent rester sur l'île ils n'ont
qu'une seule solution c'est s'inscrire
dans le collège privé de l'ilpa ce qu'il
faut dire que dans cette île
l'influencent catholique au niveau de
l'enseignement est très importante alors
la création de ce collège public a bien
sûr posé beaucoup de problèmes
eh bien on regarde votre reportage voilà
il y a quelques jours encore ses élèves
de sixième étaient à la rue pas de
locaux et pas la moindre salle en
perspective en catastrophe la commune
leur a prêté deux salles vétustes dans
un bâtiment désaffecté de l'école
primaire
et pourtant ces enfants vivent sans le
savoir un moment historique
l'implantation d'un collège laïque en
plein coeur d'un bastion de l'école
privée l'île de groix
désormais les enfants en âge d'aller au
collège auront le choix
et toi qu'est ce que tu préfères
collègues dans cette île de 2500
habitants l'enseignement a de tout temps
et l affaire de l'église et la plupart
du temps de qualité
on appelait alors l'école de jules ferry
l'école du diable
andy est la prière à l'école et une
petite paye l emportant tous les jours
c'était comme ça ah oui c'est maintenant
or maintenant je sais pas pratique de
classe contente au total ces élèves
attendre la construction de préfabriqués
pour fonctionner une concurrence
sérieuse pour l'autre collège le
catholique installé ici depuis dix ans
et qui compte lui plus de 120 élèves ici
pour rallumer une guerre scolaire je
suis venu simplement pour essayer de
mettre en place un service public
malgré tout le ministère agit un peu
vite quand même en décider des crédits
trois jours avant la rentrée pour la
création de deux postes ça paraît un peu
impératif
oui c'est pas tout à fait exact que vous
dites la création des postes la création
des postes budgétaires étaient décidés
dès la fin juin
mais effectivement il ya eu certaines
lenteurs pendant les vacances mais je
pourrais vous retourner la question ou
deux ans vous disant où étiez vous
messieurs au mois d'août
les fonctionnaires du ministère de
l'autorité centrale les fonctionnaires
durée droit les fonctionnaires
académique qui était aussi sans doute
sur les plages c'est ce qui a expliqué
certaines lenteurs effectivement le
dossier est réapparu dès la fin août
début septembre
alors à toute vitesse on a demandé sans
l'avoir consulté auparavant l'aide de la
municipalité qui voit dans cette
opération une attaque en règle contre
l'école catholique à la mairie nous
avons voulu savoir
réponse du maire pas question de faire
de déclaration encore moins de recevoir
des journalistes au presbytère monsieur
le curé quand surnomme ici le recteur
n'a lui non plus rien à dire
enfin au collège catholique on a
également choisi le silence ici en fait
dans l'île de groix on préfère régler la
guerre scolaire en silence loin du
continent et de la télévision pourtant
derrière les problèmes d'effectifs
derrière les crédits se pose une
question directement politique
fini les pensionnats sur le continent
aujourd'hui les partisans de l'école
laïque pour en scolariser leurs enfants
dans l'île
alors serge raffy a raison c'est un
problème politique dominique laurie
va-t-il être résolus bientôt écoutez moi
je vous dirai pas grand chose que je
puis vous dire et je n'ai pas tellement
nouveau c'est que les négociations entre
le ministère de l'éducation et les
responsables de l'enseignement libre
vont commencer disons début novembre
mais c'est vrai que c'est un dossier
difficile alors